CRAIG BOX: Anthos is Google
Cloud's new open platform
that lets you run an
app anywhere, simply,
flexibly, and securely.
With Anthos, we bring
the cloud to you.
You will have heard a
lot about Kubernetes
in the last few years.
I mean, it's five
years old this year,
so why aren't you running
it at your company yet?
Maybe you feel that Kubernetes
is meant more for startups
or digital companies,
because not everyone has
the luxury of moving
immediately to the cloud.
And let's be clear.
Your company does want
to move to the cloud.
It's on the long term plan.
The reality is your team
has faced many roadblocks.
You have an on-prem environment
full of legacy systems,
and you don't feel ready to
make the move to the cloud.
Some systems can't
move to the cloud
for one reason or another due to
regulatory or compliance needs.
From what you've
learned, it seems
like running Kubernetes
on-prem is challenging.
There are a multitude of options
to run it, including hundred
or so do it yourself methods.
And the project maintains
a fast release cycle.
Those updates provide
helpful security features,
but that also means
needing someone
to manage and frequently
roll out updates.
That's like giving someone
a puppy for their birthday.
They'll love it, but they'll
have to do a ton of work.
You want to care about keeping
services up and operational,
and making sure there are
no security incidents.
While your developers think
about binaries and containers,
as an operator, you are
concerned about SLAs and users.
You're worried if you make
it too easy to run things,
your developers could
choose to run anything
risking destandardization.
As an administrator,
you need to be
able to dictate policies and
decide which apps can talk
to which network endpoints.
For example, requiring
applications to be
signed to run.
And then on top
of that, you want
observability of your
applications and services.
This is where GKE
On-Prem comes into play.
It lets you take
advantage of Kubernetes
and cloud technology
in your data center.
The creators of
Kubernetes have built
an enterprise-grade environment
with the lifecycle and upgrades
managed by Google engineers.
GKE On-Prem installs into your
existing vSphere environment.
You create a
cluster, and then you
can run the entire ecosystem
of Kubernetes tools with it.
You can manage the
applications you deploy
to a GKE On-Prem environment
using the Google Cloud Console
that you use for cloud workloads
giving you unified management.
This also means when
you are ready to move
to a hybrid architecture,
you can very easily
move your applications to
the same platform running
in the cloud using
GKE on Google Cloud.
When you choose
Google, we give you
a solution that lets
you adopt Kubernetes
and its many benefits
without necessarily
having to move immediately
to the public cloud.
You will enjoy faster
time to market,
lower administrative overhead,
and increased innovation.
Plus, you have
consistent management
of applications deployed
in GKE on Google Cloud.
You get best of
breed tools built
for how Google runs services
based on the Istio service
mesh and Stackdriver.
By thinking services
first, you can
automate policy and
security at scale
at a higher layer in the stack
enabling greater awareness,
consistency, and control
at the application level,
not at the container level.
And finally, you get access
to all the modern tooling
for DevOps and SRE on top
of the Kubernetes platform,
and easy deployment of popular
applications from the GCP
marketplace.
With GKE and GKE
On-Prem, you can
overcome the trade-offs once
faced with hybrid approaches
to the cloud.
You get Kubernetes managed
by its creators at Google,
and you can dedicate more time
to serving your own customers.
To learn more about
Kubernetes and GKE, please
subscribe to our channel.